all right
um very interesting post to the David
packman show subreddit Yesterday by a
user named s Daga
and S Daga asks the question will
conservatives go after lgbtq plus
teachers next all the rhetoric about
keeping kids quote safe from LGBT people
is ridiculous I worry they might
actually start targeting folks whose job
it is to work with children parents want
to screen curriculum their child is
presented is screening of their child's
teacher next the school I recently
retired from had about 75 professional
staff several identify as gay or bi one
is a trans man one teacher is married to
a trans man LGBT people are in all our
communities I think that it is almost a
certainty that we are going to start
seeing this at least anecdotally around
the country it's probably already
happening uh anecdotally to some degree
think about it okay the transition think
about the things they're already saying
uh discussions of LGBT people sexual
orientation transgender
Etc that's already bad it's off the
table it's dangerous okay drag shows
drag time story hour all these different
things very very bad can't do it can't
do it using the pronouns that a student
wants to go by
shouldn't do it it's very bad should
always use pronouns that match
biological sex at Birth I guess they
mean at Birth
the natural next thing would be to say
not only is it dangerous to kids to hear
discussion of LGBT topics and the fact
that LGBT people exist
it must be so irresistible for LGBT
teachers to talk about it that we have
to be worried about the mere presence of
LGBT teachers in the classroom
seems perfectly logical if you follow
the deranged Republican logic they will
use the same tired arguments that we've
heard for many years they'll say well
listen children at age eight shouldn't
be around any sexualization or
indoctrination and when I see my kids
gay teacher or trans teacher it is
highly sexual and it is an
indoctrination so we've got to get rid
of them now of course they just want to
silence and punish teachers who are
openly LGBT many of them probably
believe if my kid's teacher is LGBT it
might convince or brainwash my kid into
being LGBT or whatever the case may be
and it's really important to understand
that they already are using the framing
of danger to children and parents rights
and so they are simply going to adapt
that existing terminology to LGBT
teachers listen I don't want my kid
recruited I don't want my kids
development
stifled in any way I don't want this
ideology pushed on them I don't want any
of it now these arguments are of course
baseless but they are so deeply harmful
to people who are either openly part of
the LGBT community
um or not yet openly part of it they are
discriminatory in I believe at this
point every state it would be and it's
really important to understand that
these attacks on teachers who identify
as LGBT will just be the latest attempt
to do the things that they've wanted to
do all along we should stigmatize LGBT
status we should marginalize those
individuals and they've already passed
bills and laws of All Sorts to do that
including don't say gay so to the
question are they going to go after the
LGBT teachers next
I'm not a betting man but I would bet
that at least at the local level on some
small scale we're going to see it if not
through legislation more broadly let me
know what you think